introduced actually a Dallas person
gemstone he is the chief data scientist
at fair compare and he's worked for a
match com previously so he's kind of on
the cutting edge of some of the I'm
social media analytics and then I was
very fortunate you'll notice that the
names have changed and also in the
social world the master's degree
students decided that they could not
show up at the last minute so I found
these two highly talented people because
I was being a social butterfly earlier
and there with tanay 0 which is a
company out of San Francisco that does
New York that does manic well see an
Francisco New York it's the same haha
not really and there with a management
company that does financial consulting
so we have talao mufti who's the VP of
strategy and 50 hawk he's the vice
president of data products and they've
used very large scale social media and
data sets to do network analysis and
brand strategy so I thought it would be
very interesting to have them today on
this panel and then we're also very
lucky and you guys some of you are
probably planning on attending his
session next which is going to be over
in 114 116 but I also wanted to grab
sigh he's a member of our Dallas Big
Data community and involved with Python
and he just recently gone off on his own
and founded Eddie co research and so
what we'd like to do with this panel is
I'm going to hand the microphone first
to Jeb and he's going to kind of share
his knowledge and thought leadership and
and after everybody does that will allow
for a lot of audience interaction and
for you guys ask some questions plus we
only have one microphone great thank you
it's ok hey everybody I'm Jeb actually
it's dr. James Carl still in the fourth
it is way harder to get people to call
you that than you would think so I'm not
going to ask you to raise your hands or
anything you can smile and nod but
so you know how many people have worked
for months or years on something and
they look up one day and they think oh
my god what am I spin in my life doing
yeah so that happened to me I was
finishing my master's thesis alluringly
title the instrument instrumental
conditioning of a leg lift in the
honeybee which is every bit as exciting
as you could think as you can imagine
and I realized I was in for a long and
lonely life in the lab and so I switch
gears a little bit finish my degree got
got a really cool job where I got to
found the analytics team at match com
those guys have some of the coolest best
social data that you'll find user
interactions chats all sorts of user
level data did a stint in web analytics
and helped kickstart a couple of a few
startups with their first rounds of
predictive models that leveraged social
data to to make money and to help users
and we'll talk a little bit about some
of those right now I'm with a company
called fair compare here in Dallas we're
like kayak except way more awesome good
afternoon everyone like Jeff said you
know I also did master's thesis but i
did in machine learning at the time you
know when I want the professors and
teachers talk to you they thought oak is
exciting and stuff like that but when
you got a job it is not that exciting
because nobody wants to talk about
machine learning i'm talking about a
couple of decades ago but in the last
five years things have changed couldn't
be more exciting for me AI and machine
learning are commonplace terms i see
them on cnn.com and what have you so
that has been my background and so I
work in the middle a lot on data
warehousing and business intelligence
and big data space and so forth but what
is interesting for me in this conference
is I have spoken whew Gartner bi summits
the level of conversation and discussion
whatever but I compare that to what I
see here
I feel at home a lot of nitty-gritty
about today I somebody talking about
assembly code and what have you it's
very exciting and so I'm so glad to be
here and hope I'm able to end some of
your questions on our social media and
so forth hi everyone my name is Tom of
tea so I'm a data scientist at a new
york-based management consulting firm
called tanay oh I started off actually
as an industrial engineer and then
realized less interested in that kind of
like this thing called operations
research kind of probability things like
that went into the masses in that and
then discovered oh I really need to
build models that are not just
statistical but that actually can feed
in and pull in data and so I was like I
should teach myself Python this looks
pretty popular and all of a sudden now
I'm a data scientist at a consulting
company having started off Moore's you
know more brick and mortar engineer it's
exciting so some of the work will be
talking about is in using available
social media data crowdsourcing marriage
you know marrying that to a traditional
survey research and how to do sentiment
analysis and things like that how to use
that to drive brand strategy and I'll
hand it over to my colleague who also
does something syncs up with that hi
guys my name is fires Oh Huck I'm also
ateneo a colleague of tell-alls my
technical or official title there is VP
of data products but I've done
everything from you know putting
together spreadsheets to coding to
mocking things up in PowerPoint who by
the way does mock-ups on PowerPoint um
just one person I thought they'd be more
it's a there's somebody giving me a
thumbs down there I worked at Microsoft
as well before this and I let you into a
secret they also do their mock ups on
PowerPoint that's hence the ribbon and
Clippy and everything else everything
else you love in addition what talal
just said we also use social media data
to construct large networks and what we
do with that is your traditional you
sensuality analysis to find out who is
the influencer who's influencing the
conversation or conversations within
specific communities and the fascinating
thing that I found when I first started
doing this thing about a year ago was
that for even very large conversations
say you know three to four million
social media posts in the end it's
really about 150 to 200 people or
driving most of the conversation and
that's mind-boggling it's you know that
level of influence it's it's very kind
of top-heavy and that obviously you know
leads to very interesting things when
you're advising companies on things like
corporate strategy brand strategy and
things which have usually been informed
by your traditional Survey Research
you're trying to do some of the things
with social media data so it's a it's a
space that's probably different to what
most people here are familiar with so we
thought you know we could talk more but
more about that and how we use
traditional data science techniques to
inform practices in an industry which
has traditionally been very sort of you
know six and stones for the lack of a
better term so I guess if you take our
title here social media analytics Python
and you kind of cut that in half maybe
we can start with Python and I don't
know about you guys but I didn't I
didn't start out with Python you know I
started out with a SAS way back when
still use it it's a it's great tool but
so the question is and and we'll get
into some of the nitty-gritty I guess
with with the what our social media
analytics are but why Python what what
does it bring to the table that you're
using that is either you know valuable
or quicker or what's the value
proposition for that so that's a very
good question from my perspective here I
do believe an experience in
multi-strategy learning because if you
look at it how we as humans learn we
have multiple sensory organization
multiple things that we look at
so if I apply a particular machine
learning algorithm let's say a decision
tree versus plastering versus new lads
I'm going to get different things
identified from that information so that
led me to do more on the NLP side i was
using stanford natural language
processing libraries a lot but to the
point that i believe in the multi
strategy learning and parameters
influence and so forth i stumbledupon
NLT k natural language toolkit and that
is why i started to learn python so as
you like you I wasn't starting with
Python but I've heard a lot about it I
heard someone mentioned that it is for
administrators and stuff like that but
when I saw Python and LG care I might
open up and I found a last area of
things that you can do so in the target
i'm going to talk about after this
conversation i'm going to compare some
of the results that NLT k provided and
what the stanford NLP provided and the
differences but what I like about NM TK
is you could extend configure to how you
want to classify text right for example
you have a particular pattern of
concepts that you're searching in your
and a glass array of a textual
information you could create a chunker
based on that and you can have your
python power to go find those kind of
information that kind of flexibility
when i learned and made sense and that's
one of the reason why you know concert
like this makes sense for me because now
I have a machine learning algorithm
implementations in python that i could
leverage I don't have to go from one
representation of information from one
language to the other that's my exciting
fun so for me I guess the interesting
thing that I can admit now that I
actually have a job and I think
hopefully my you know my resume doesn't
look too bad is that I start off wanting
to be a computer scientist and didn't do
well enough in the weider class of
computer science so I have done the AP
which is basically a high school
advanced placement test for her designs
and I thought I was hot [ __ ] but I never
actually programmed anything on a
compute
was all on paper and I'm like okay I'm
gonna skip the intro class and go
straight to Java too and I mean I didn't
fail but I didn't do very well and that
really influenced me a lot because in
the beginning I'm like oh man you know
I'm just not that good at it I tried
again you know i retook the class did a
little better took an algorithms class
and that really set up the basis for me
as a maybe not a computer scientist but
someone who is who uses programming what
got me back into it was computational
programming so I start off with matlab
just because schools use it and then did
are because i did some stats classes
where they preferred open source stuff
and then kind of left it for a while had
to suffer my Master's even though it's
an operations research my funding was
from the transportation program so i
built a basically highly disaggregate
transportation model that simulated
every trip down to like a census block
in all of New Jersey it's not that I
could talk more about that but in any
case I was like okay I need to now go
back I need to do some real programming
not just computational stuff am I gonna
do this in our my news in Java and some
people like Oh have you looked at Python
and it was so easy to pick up and I've
just been you know using it ever since
really for everything just the
versatility of it alone not a real
computer scientists can't other people
can speak to how good python is in those
regards better than I can but that's how
I that's how I got hooked so I think my
gateway drug to python was Django back
in school and I was prototyping some
apps up that was my like framework of
choice but then I think I think it's
just and this is what everybody else has
been saying and how liquid it's just the
vast diversity of things that you can do
in in Python or libraries that are
available in Python and are well
supported with great communities it's
it's amazing I think very few other
languages today could boast that so you
know you've got I like ateneo for
example we have our web apps being
served by Django we do some natural NLP
stuff with an otk
a we run our network analytics with dato
shout out to D these guys are awesome I
love them and you know we also use CyHi
and pandas to do more kind of you know
SVM based learning models as well so
it's that diversity I think that keeps
us hooked to it that said though I think
there are things that don't work well
with Python too so one thing for example
that i found was constructing networks
what large data sets so again using
social media data you know if there's
you've a data set of 3 million posts
constructing it in network X is
extremely inefficient I'd love to hear
from anybody who knows a way to do it
more efficiently but you know in the end
we ended up having to work with the
Tinker pop stack and work directly in in
gremlin and right and groovy which
allows the same networks will be
constructed you know 10 to 20 times
faster so there are things that it's not
so great for so I'd ask that question to
the panel as well are the things that
you found that Python limits you from
doing and what was your work around that
well kind of kind of start with the good
and go to the bad here you know I i
guess i came to Python from a little
different direction than then so many
guys I had the environment has changed
the data environment the analysis
environments have changed a lot in the
past few years and it used to be the
case that if you're going to get data
you knew what was in it you knew it was
pretty clean and they just kind of gave
it to you all right those were the days
like and now so now we've got all this
data on all these api's and this you
know unstructured data which sometimes
it means unstructured sometimes it means
well nobody looked at it we just dumped
it on the cluster and so Python for me
has really opened up the door being able
letting me get at that data letting me
fix it clean it up restructure it into a
model able program and I've really
appreciated that about it as far as
things it doesn't do well you know the
sass program is what 60 years the holes
or something at this point and so it
does some things in a few lines of code
that that still Python takes takes looks
more like a Java to do a you know a proc
freq or something like that it's just a
lot a lot more code to do that kind of
thing but at the same time then I'll say
you know yesterday I was working on
loading a was 250 million record data
set into a sequel liked so I could run
some queries on it because I couldn't
get my sequel to return a query on 250
million records which is not that big
but so I can load that into sequel light
and you know a couple of minutes friend
some queries on it dump the data set and
up that what I need so there's really
been a fantastic when you need it's a
neat database application as well you
know about the network that's a very
good question in fact I do rely a lot on
we do rely a lot on network X but one of
the things that I've learned in
optimizing anything is obviously you
know no matter what tool sets you pick
your going to hit you know some
performance limit so we looked at the
network that you're forming and we you
know we figured out a way to carve the
network out to a smaller size and so we
have multiple networks if you will of
network X object that I can in a managed
within the time frame so we use that to
deploy each network on a Hadoop cluster
and that's one of the way how we tackle
that but even then they want to hear we
hit a performance limit and so I had to
actually use you know an open source
package from CMU Pegasus that massively
scales on Hadoop so I know there are but
there are certain things that graph your
graphics does which Pegasus does not do
for example finding the best path and
and so forth because we need do we don't
need to find out how far the influencer
or the follower is a wave
the seller topic and whatnot so those
kind of algorithms work better in
network so what we do is we do a lot of
back and forth to make that thing happen
but we found a way to figure out a car
mount the pieces of network and a scale
O'Hagan I think pretty much everyone's
covered it at this point uh issues I've
had with Python or what it doesn't do
well for me um hmm honestly pandas has
changed my life so I I mostly have
positive things to say not nothing
nothing top of mind comes two comes to
me right now so but we can press on I
suppose I guess Jets got another
question so let's start we going to
dissect it our topic in the two groups
so going back to the social media part
what's the coolest thing that that you
guys have done with Python on social
media analytics for me the coolest thing
you know typically since where I am at
today it's about getting value out of
these technologies right that's what if
somebody asked me during lunch you know
what would you be the one deliverable in
big data space that you would tell your
customer to you know make sense a lot of
my customers have you know
infrastructure big data stuff on they
have a Python there are all kinds of
things but what they're missing is how
do I get the business value from what it
is so from that perspective you know in
a social media what we are doing today
is you know when you are let us say a
premium customer off a company that
company knows a lot about you because
you transact with them you tell them
stuff and you know you are probably
giving some in a feedback and what have
you they know a lot about you and they
use that to help you to get better
service but the question that some of my
clients asking is is that enough how can
I find more of my premium customers in a
space that I have no information about
tumors to us social media gives us that
framework say let us say you know we
bought five different airlines right for
example but we both may be active on
social media and having similar
conversations
so if you and I are like-minded in terms
of what we say and what they like if you
have information about your company and
if they can somehow socially engage with
me potentially I could be their customer
too so that's a kind of coolest thing
from your question perspective makes
sense because we are now actually using
social media to add value when we say
value it's not about just selling
something it's about how can I make
things for you because it's a connected
world like we all need different
services to do what you want to do how
can I offer additional services to you
so that you can do what you do best and
that's a coolest story from my
perspective so to me I think generally
speaking taking Python inside
momentarily one of the most interesting
things looking at social media has just
been how how human it actually is when
you actually look at a lot of posts and
some of that unfortunately ends up
really meaning it's noise and you have
to take it out because it's just an
anecdote about some of the you know say
you're looking at a product or a brand
that you're trying to explore the
conversation around and yet seeing those
things you're like you know these are
these are people who you or your
otherwise completely anonymous that you
are seeing their posts you're seeing
what they're thinking I think the end I
mean interestingly enough ultimately i'd
like to have to do less of that i'd like
to be able to write a product so good
that it pulls data from the right
vendors uploads it to the right
crowdsourcing platform codes it the
right way applies the right machine
learning and spits out and yet you know
that would be great and that's probably
what we need to do we need to get to
that level but having that human element
in between where i have to actually look
at things and use my knowledge of pop
culture to be like oh this is not
actually about that company this is
about some cartoon or 80s TV show that's
actually referring to it like Alibaba or
something like that so that human aspect
to me has been really interesting
looking at social media
but from a Python perspective I also
look forward to putting it all together
so well that I don't need to do that and
I can sleep more at night I think
especially in the marketing research
space there's been a fundamental shift
where we used to be where the modus
operandi used to be sent out surveys you
know there are people whose job it is to
go to households all over America and
sit with people with with these families
and ask some questions these long
booklets of questions that ask them from
you know questions like the TV shows
that they watch or the brand of
toothpaste that they use and their
attitude towards NASCAR vs indy 500 and
it's this really thick booklet and just
imagine you know the amount of
investment that used to go into
collecting these service actually still
does I mean these companies are still
doing it come like companies like
Simmons and MRI so it's a huge
operational challenge and obviously the
cost it's very prohibitive so if you
want to use the survey data you have to
shell out a lot of money and a lot of
smaller companies a lot of smaller
brands don't have that ability to pay
that much money but now what's happening
the what would the fundamental shift
that's happened is instead of asking
people questions you infer their
opinions from what they are saying on
social media and you know obviously the
barrier to entry is much lower as well
when you're working with social media
data obviously that means that there's a
lot more noise as well and there's that
bias you introduced by simply having to
infer a person's opinion from what
they're saying as opposed to just asking
them what they're saying so an example I
give you an to answer you know again the
coolest project that I worked on was for
LeBron James who is a client of ours and
we're helping him you know become the
CEO of his own brand so that's an
interesting way to think about athletes
these days someone like LeBron James
isn't just a player he doesn't just you
know shoot hoops he is the CEO of his
brand he's the spokesperson for samsung
he
when he wears beats by dr. dre
headphones that you know spikes sales of
the of that product infinitely not
infinitely by but by you know quite a
bit significantly and so to take
everything that's being said about
LeBron out there and then establish what
his brand actually is today what do
people associate him with you know is it
is it Khia that I think of when he when
I think of LeBron James and the kind of
car that he drives or is it Ferrari or
is it beats by dr. dre or you know cuz
headphones so when you help him
establish that his brand what it is
right now is does it appeal to young
urban males or does it appeal to you
know old older 50-plus women and then
what he aspires to be a ten years from
now you know you can use all that's been
said about LeBron in conjunction with
the different brands that he has
sponsorships with today and and tell him
advise him that hey actually at the
sponsorship that she had with McDonald's
was not very resonant like people
weren't looking at it very favorably
whereas the sponsorship that she had
would beats you know made a lot of sense
to people it resonated with people and
you know it contributed to your brand
and it also will help you take your
brand to the place that you aspire to be
in 10 years from now you know you can
you can start to do that by using all
this data that's available out there and
yes I think that that was kind of cool a
cool project I also see a lot of
confused faces in the audience right now
site also asked you guys what would you
be interested in us talking about are
there specific areas that you know we
can talk about or focus on that me that
might be interesting sure
the one that comes to mind is the creepy
the creepiness factor like what happened
with targeted he was 2008-2009 when a
father basic when they used their
shopping behavior and a father found out
his daughter was pres teenage daughter
was pregnant because of the ads how do
you overcome things that would basically
do things like freak someone out because
of how much you know how would you make
it more seem more inferred and less over
so I think the answer to that right now
right now we're in what is the wild wild
west of social media like you know it's
free for all all these social media
platforms are open anybody can look at
what you're saying and so in this wild
wild west the moral responsibility falls
on us you know people who are analyzing
that data to make sure that you're
following best practices you're holding
yourself to a high ethical standard and
I know that will not make any of you or
especially people are not in this room
very comfortable that it's a bunch of
nerds or holding themselves to you know
high ethical standards and nobody wants
that so to make those people feel at
ease I would also say that this wild
wild west is going to end pretty soon
recently Facebook announced that they're
cutting off access to even their public
facebook posts to marketing agencies or
anyone actually like anyone right now
could go and search for all the posts on
football or on NFL right now that are
public so you know their privacy privacy
setting is public and that's going to
stop so Facebook is anonymizing that
access you can find out what topics
people are talking about when they talk
about NFL and what the demographics of
people are like age groups and gender
when they're talking about NFL but you
won't actually get to see that hey this
is a person who came into my target
store she's now on social media talking
about I don't know condoms and therefore
she's probably pregnant you won't be
able to do that that that individual
matching ability is going to become much
harder even though you know there's
research coming out of MIT that yeah
sure it you know it's a really
interesting question think I think we
can think about it another way when
you're when you're speaking with people
person a person you're having a
conversation and sometimes something
crosses your mind that you realize maybe
I shouldn't say that I'm not going to
bring up all the problems that his
sisters have whatever because there's a
group it's a conversation and I think
what gets lost sometimes is some of the
social data is not only fun and
interesting it's it's monetizable we can
make money off of it and I think what
gets lost sometimes in the transit
translation from kind of kind of the
modeling side to the product side is at
the end of the day what you're applying
your social data towards needs to still
be social it needs to be part of a
conversation that's not that much
different than what we might have and
you know to come straight back to the
target example don't have conversations
about somebody's potential pregnancy
when a lot of other people are in the
room right i mean it's i think it's that
simple it just kind of got lost in the
in the translation when they had these
monetization objectives so um I i
console a lot of my clients the
enterprise level in the data warehousing
bi space you probably heard this thing
called data governance it's a very
important factor and so now to the point
there a great question about the social
media is available and so I'm you know
my goal is a monetize I can do anything
I want the wild wild west so some of the
things that some responsible enterprises
all learning from these experiences any
knowledge that you derive from no matter
what it is your transactions of social
media need to be covered today there are
a lot of loss about what information I
can use to approve a loan or not right
there is the rest of rules so likewise
those rules are self-imposed if you will
you know that's what I think you said
that you know it's all our practices
like us need to be very cognizant of it
so you know a lot of times when I
implement a machine learning rules
engine processing results we also ask
our enterprises okay please put in a
governance structure around it and we
talked about it before we implement some
organizations are good at that and some
are not but eventually you know that's
one way to police these things that
happens so I think it's been pretty well
covered unless anyone else wants to
touch on that I mean certainly the the
one other factor is the source
themselves and like five said Facebook
for example are aggregating and
anonymizing it monetizing it themselves
effectively through a third party vendor
and I think twitter's about to do the
same thing for some of its data or sorry
i'm not sure they'll anonymize that
completely but yeah they're certainly
building more safeguards around it yeah
so I guess you know that's sort of a to
be continued but to any other questions
so I guess I'll repeat the question well
first of all do you seem to understand
it better p I i I'm not familiar well
you know I don't know if Python the
question is are there any artifacts and
libraries or guards to enforce VII in
Python I'm not aware of okay
is it I I don't know if I just was
trying to raise yeah okay so what we
read from that is there are people who
do that would you like to hear more
about that right so okay great I well I
work for Z Omega and we have a product
that is bound by HIPAA regulations it's
in the health care industry it's it's
written in Python it's very mature it's
it's I mean its first release was in
2003 it's all you know a Python
JavaScript application with an SQL
backend and our customers really are
really really care about this issue and
so we have to have a lot of security
functionality in our application to
track to track who all has actually seen
the data as they navigate through our
application as they generate reports who
all has actually modified it and so
there's a lot of sort of audit reports
that are required for personally
identifiable information and ph I PII is
personally identifiable information and
ph I is personal health information and
so these are both areas of concern and
there's also a lot of processes that
your organization has to put into place
to ensure that you have security
controls on who has access to that data
and and you have to be able to
demonstrate that that your application
has those controls I don't does that is
that enough information yeah and I think
that's just it is that you need an
organization like HIPAA to really get a
majority of people to follow such rules
or to actually enforce any such
guidelines but yeah I mean there's
anyone else have any experience with
that or
panel here so I think you were talking
about this yesterday as all the
regulation one thing to just be aware in
this case is that regulations sometimes
fall behind technology as well something
though there are lots of regulation
around what kind of credit card
transaction data companies can collect
you know they're like it has to be
anonymised you can only record the
amount and I think the place where it
happened there are three data points I I
forget exactly what it was but it's very
strictly defined but recently an MIT
paper came out that said that that's
enough like those three data points are
enough to actually point the person who
made that transaction by just like
harmonizing different data sets and you
know combining those different data
points so just one thing to be aware
just to add to that point in a previous
life I worked with the database
marketing organization and my takeaway
from that is what falls under PII
because like a Twitter hashtag like to
use like you say regulation kind of
follows behind technology someone's
address it obviously is you know
personally identifiable but a Twitter
hashtag you know how would that fall in
your opinion because my experience they
they safeguard had safeguards around
address and telephone number but if you
have someone's email address and you can
get their hashtag I think it's a pretty
short trip to be able to identify that
person based on the information that
this company was gathering for many of
their companies so that was just an
observation I had that experience I
think that's a really important point
and again goes to show that you know you
need to put guard rails and yourself so
one thing that Facebook does for is
going to do for example is not give you
any data point where there are fewer
than hundred people that talked about
that issue so you know things like a
hashtag if there's only one person who's
talked about who's used that hashtag and
if you know even if you scrub out there
handle you're able to identify them by
retro actively looking for that hashtag
but with those kind of guard rails were
you're aggregating data and you're
saying that if it's less if u're than
hundred people people who use that
hashtag we will not show that the
information to you so definitely I think
the regulation is probably not enough in
this in this space and more needs to be
done the definition of PA is constantly
changing the old definition included not
your email address and hashtags but the
newer definition includes that therefore
when people are implementing any
procedure they have to upgrade that for
the including in the new definition
so the question is how much is how much
does pii changed I what cadence how
frequently I am a user I just follow
that but I have been noticing it only
very recently the definition of PIAA has
changed it has remained static for a
very long time so I do not know the
frequency they are planning to use but
like you mentioned that if you look at
your hashtag that is lot more personal
information just from the hashtag so
that is where they want to protect that
those kind of information I do not know
of any periodicity there each in this is
different from a financial industry
perspective there about seven levels of
yeah I at this moment it could be more
depends on ID also and also one point
about yeah is no matter what kind of
programming languages you use and what
kind of its at the data actual control
access and control think about even you
encrypt it you got to separate the
encryption key from development versus
production this their lot of issues and
that's a biggest challenge in the big
data space because a lot of unstructured
data and lot of the comments that are
coming in lot of the customers they put
in their bank account for example how do
you encrypt it how do you safeguard it
when it goes into the final data stores
how do you know scrub it and then make
sure you put a hash on the top of it so
that nobody can see it it's a biggest
challenge order one question for you
guys what kind of technical challenges
you faced in terms of the size of the
database you know dealing with the no
complex even the complex Python programs
i know there are lots of limits that are
being broken and then being challenged
but what kind of limits that you guys
have seen in terms of the sizes of the
databases and data sets right i mean
again from my perspective you know 3 to
4 4 million edges and having to
translate that into a graph a network
that's been the biggest sort of
challenge so that translation from rose
to to a to a connected graph
so if you're getting you know simple
tweets for example it tells you be
handled the person it said something a
person may be the handle of the the
person that retweeted that they
retweeted and some structure information
as well but like constructing networks
out of it that has been a challenge
especially with Python and it's right
now actually not even terabytes several
hundred gigabytes so half a terabyte in
some cases but I've never liked you even
you know for 25 million tweets for
example when translating into a terabyte
if I could add to that you know there
are a lot of definitions of big data I
think one of the more interesting ones
i've heard is you know the data are so
large that you need to take the analysis
to the data rather than bringing the
data to the analysis the first couple of
years i worked with worked on hadoop it
was really rough there wasn't a lot of
standardization you end up with data
streamed out as serialized java objects
it's hard to hard to play in that
environment the i think more recently
you've seen a lot more standardization
around file types you've got Avro you've
got kite almost everything will people
don't fight you when you want something
in hive these days so I spent I did a
fair bit of work with some MapReduce
programs in Python I found that to be
very effective also easy to do on a
relatively easy to do on an environment
that was not very beginner friendly
early on spark though for me has really
changed a lot of things it has it's a
much more efficient data access paradigm
for large data sets you know it has the
same still has some reality constraints
just like any anything else however were
able to do i'm able to do a lot more
with with spark in a lot less code more
efficiently than i was able to do before
so that's that's that's been a tool I've
really been using this one is this data
set we had
I don't remember maybe a terabyte a day
coming in and it's you know you have to
you can't read it all but you can if you
index it right you can you can read
enough of it what are give it the same
thing about using hadoop mapreduce in
Python or Java helps us to manage the
performance challenges i said earlier
mentioned there is always some business
knowledge that you can incorporate to
manage your performance right people say
that you know like eighty ninety percent
of the world's data is going to be
unstructured but how much of that
applies to your organization if you put
in that context it isn't big so up in
the game the stream you apply the
necessary filters to manage your
performance is one way to tackle that
but you know decide that you do need
infrastructure like I do and I like the
way you said about you know using Python
itself but they're using Hadoop
streaming you can run MapReduce code and
that works beautiful so I think we're
just about out of time if f yeah do you
want to have anything else to add files
all right well I guess that that wraps
it up f is any really really pressing
things before we say goodbye I've thank
you all very much